Caption: going to kick us off today is Dawn Dawn
Caption: e collet Dawn likes to Tinker with Cloud
Caption: infrastructure and security and
Caption: regularly goes down rabbit holes in a
Caption: futile search
Caption: a futile search for ways to develop
Caption: systems that are both reliable and
Caption: impenetrable as well as accidental
Caption: accessibility advocacy Dawn can
Caption: regularly be found sharing knowledge
Caption: within the Melbourne Cloud
Caption: infrastructure and devops communities
Caption: outside work Dawn is an occasional
Caption: author a kitchen Alchemist and a raging
Caption: sports ball fan over to you Dawn
Caption: thank you
Caption: can everyone hear me am I hooked up to
Caption: the AV
Caption: so I was supposed to come here today to
Caption: talk to you about web accessibility
Caption: but unfortunately on my flight from
Caption: Melbourne to Perth yesterday my talk was
Caption: disabled so I'm going to spend
Caption: approximately the next 45 minutes
Caption: explaining to you how we go about
Caption: re-enabling it if you want to follow
Caption: along with the sources that I used when
Caption: I was putting together this talk you can
Caption: scan that QR code up there or go to the
Caption: GitHub link that will take you to a
Caption: GitHub repository which has all of the
Caption: sources sorted by type
Caption: to begin with I want to acknowledge the
Caption: fact that I am presenting today on
Caption: Aboriginal land I want to acknowledge
Caption: the traditional owners of the land here
Caption: the wajukununga people and also the war
Caption: injury people of the colon Nation on
Caption: Whose land this talk came into being
Caption: this country is and always will be
Caption: Aboriginal land their sovereignty was
Caption: never ceded
Caption: I also want to tip my hat to the old men
Caption: and women the Aboriginal and Torres
Caption: Strait Islander mentors that I myself
Caption: had growing up because among many other
Caption: incredibly valuable lessons that I
Caption: learned from them they taught me about
Caption: the importance of stories and I wouldn't
Caption: be here giving this presentation to you
Caption: today without them
Caption: I also want to thank all of the sponsors
Caption: who have made this possible it has been
Caption: amazing to be able to come from
Caption: Melbourne to Perth to do this all ready
Caption: to meet so many awesome people and it
Caption: would not be possible without all of the
Caption: sponsors
Caption: you've kind of got the introduction
Caption: there that's me my name is Dawn my day
Caption: job is I'm an engineer at enabler we are
Caption: a tiny little consultancy in Melbourne
Caption: we love solving devops and cloudy type
Caption: problems that's what I do in my day job
Caption: if you want to know more about that you
Caption: can ask me more but the reason that I'm
Caption: here speaking to all of you today is
Caption: because I am an accidental accessibility
Caption: Advocate we're going to get back to that
Caption: one
Caption: as Hannah said outside work I am an
Caption: occasional author and kitchen Alchemist
Caption: sometimes that ends really well
Caption: sometimes doesn't I am also a raging
Caption: sports ball fan hence that picture and
Caption: this being me in Boston Bruins clothing
Caption: that's a hockey team for the record
Caption: so The Accidental accessibility Advocate
Caption: bit the last two words of that are very
Caption: easy to understand
Caption: The Accidental is a bit less so and in
Caption: order to explain that I need to take you
Caption: on a little bit of a tour
Caption: and we are going to start that tour in
Caption: the UK with this excellent disabled
Caption: toilet which is down the set of stairs
Caption: I don't know if any of you have ever
Caption: tried to take a wheelchair down a set of
Caption: stairs do not recommend
Caption: over in New Zealand much closer to home
Caption: we do actually have a ramp to be able to
Caption: get into this building but unfortunately
Caption: for the poor power chair user who's
Caption: currently sitting and staring at it it
Caption: is blocked off by a couple of large
Caption: orange traffic cones again if you want
Caption: to get into the building not absolutely
Caption: conducive to that
Caption: and finally the place where I could save
Caption: this talk in the place where I live in
Caption: Melbourne we have these exalus around
Caption: the place Space Age public toilets if
Caption: you will
Caption: and the reason why these made it into a
Caption: talk about accidental accessibility
Caption: advocacy is because they have a cleaning
Caption: cycle which runs and that is indicated
Caption: by a large light which will go on in the
Caption: cubicle of the toilet
Caption: there is also a panel in the toilet
Caption: which explains that when the large light
Caption: goes on you should vacate because it's
Caption: about to start its cleaning cycle
Caption: that panel is translated into Braille
Caption: Braille blind people light
Caption: doesn't quite compute that
Caption: so
Caption: before I get on let's define a few
Caption: important terms
Caption: to begin with disability by the
Caption: Australian definition is a continuing
Caption: condition which restricts everyday
Caption: activities A continuing condition means
Caption: that it's likely to last for six months
Caption: or more the restricting everyday
Caption: activities bit is fairly
Caption: self-explanatory
Caption: then there's accessibility and that's
Caption: the degree to which an activity can be
Caption: done by everyone
Caption: now this is not just about disability
Caption: one case study that I like to use here
Caption: is from about December 2009 if anyone
Caption: remembers hp's racist webcam where a
Caption: black gentleman had gone out and bought
Caption: himself a state-of-the-art HP laptop
Caption: which had a wonderful web camera which
Caption: was supposed to be able to do facial
Caption: recognition except it couldn't until he
Caption: got his white co-worker to test it
Caption: and then there's adaptive technology and
Caption: those are tools that disabled people to
Caption: use to improve access
Caption: that can be exceptionally low-tech this
Caption: my walking stick is a piece of adaptive
Caption: technology wheelchairs are adaptive
Caption: technology some things that we use in
Caption: architecture like ramps can be part of
Caption: adaptive technology
Caption: but in the broader sense in terms of
Caption: technical pieces of adaptive technology
Caption: we're talking here about things like
Caption: screen readers things like adaptive and
Caption: augmentative communication things which
Caption: are essentially attached to a computer
Caption: and warning this is where we get
Caption: political for a minute
Caption: excuse me
Caption: as I get back to the right slide
Caption: there are broadly two different ways
Caption: that we can Define disability the
Caption: medical model and the social model
Caption: the medical model of disability holds
Caption: that disability itself is a problem that
Caption: disability is something that we should
Caption: try to resolve something that we should
Caption: try to cure and that is Illustrated here
Caption: by this clipart lob in a wheelchair
Caption: being comforted by a vaguely
Caption: doctor-looking clipart blob
Caption: on the other hand the social model holds
Caption: that it's not so much disability that's
Caption: the problem it's accessibility that we
Caption: shouldn't be trying to change people we
Caption: should be trying to change the world
Caption: around them to make it easier to
Caption: navigate and when that goes well that's
Caption: illustrated by things like adaptive
Caption: sports that we have over here you know
Caption: these people who are playing sports in
Caption: wheelchairs look perfectly happy doing
Caption: and I wouldn't want to dismiss the
Caption: medical model entirely because there are
Caption: some great interventions that have come
Caption: out of that but for the purposes of the
Caption: work that we're doing the way that I
Caption: would suggest that we look at this is
Caption: through the lens of the social model we
Caption: want to try to modify the environment to
Caption: make it easier for people to use
Caption: and if you're here I feel pretty
Caption: confident in saying that this is part of
Caption: your job
Caption: so to illustrate that let's look at a
Caption: few case studies of how this goes well
Caption: and how this goes badly
Caption: this is on grand.net and I didn't have
Caption: to look very hard to find this it's on a
Caption: great many list of top 10 worst websites
Caption: ever
Caption: and it's visually very cluttered you can
Caption: see that I mean it would probably make
Caption: more sense to me if I spoke Norwegian
Caption: but you've got a bunch of pictures here
Caption: which are all very confused you've got a
Caption: bunch of colors there's not really a
Caption: whole lot of structure to it and it
Caption: would not surprise you that if you try
Caption: to navigate on grand.net with a screen
Caption: reader you're going to have a great deal
Caption: of difficulty doing it because that
Caption: structure that's replicated that
Caption: structure that we see here visually is
Caption: replicated in the lack of structure that
Caption: you get when trying to navigate it with
Caption: a screen reader there's a hell of a lot
Caption: of red and green here and that's really
Caption: difficult for colorblind people
Caption: unsurprisingly many of the images here
Caption: don't actually have alt text and it's
Caption: also not clear which images are tied to
Caption: which links because of the lack of
Caption: structure
Caption: and then there's distinctive Design This
Caption: is Ling's cars and you may or may not
Caption: believe this but this is actually one of
Caption: the most successful Car leasing
Caption: businesses in the United Kingdom
Caption: and it is built around the brand of Ling
Caption: Valentine the owner and the brand is
Caption: obvious Ling's face is animated the uh
Caption: tongue with the British flag on it is
Caption: animated the traffic lights are animated
Caption: and my favorite bit which I couldn't get
Caption: into this screenshot from when I
Caption: originally took it was the GIF of Boris
Caption: Johnson shrugging used to illustrate the
Caption: Boris brexit guarantee that if the UK
Caption: left the EU the cost of leasing your car
Caption: would not go up
Caption: but if you want to build a distinctive
Caption: website like this there are a lot of
Caption: considerations that go into it you have
Caption: to think about things like that text
Caption: across the top that's not text that's
Caption: actually clip art so it's not
Caption: necessarily going to be immediately
Caption: apparent that that's the launching point
Caption: of your page and you also need to then
Caption: add alt text to it you can have issues
Caption: with backgrounds making it difficult for
Caption: people to navigate things
Caption: you know there is a lot of alt text that
Caption: has gone into this website but when I
Caption: originally looked at it there wasn't a
Caption: lot of it there there were a lot of
Caption: scenarios where pictures were used to
Caption: illustrate things without something that
Caption: would be backed up by a screen reader
Caption: and if you have photosensitivity
Caption: problems you are not going to have fun
Caption: trying to navigate this site
Caption: then there's an example of good design
Caption: and this is one that probably a lot of
Caption: us use every day and that is GitHub
Caption: GitHub does a few things really well
Caption: that are not necessarily intuitive to
Caption: start with if you look at that top bar
Caption: over there you can see that you've got
Caption: the GitHub logo the search bar but then
Caption: next to it you've actually got pull
Caption: request issues Marketplace explore and
Caption: those are easy anchors for screen reader
Caption: users to be able to get to the areas of
Caption: GitHub that they might frequently use
Caption: GitHub is very very good about not just
Caption: conveying information with color the
Caption: layout is quite easy to understand
Caption: visually it scales very well and this is
Caption: actually a screenshot of the nvda repo
Caption: the free and open source screen reader
Caption: for Windows and the people who developed
Caption: nvda migrated it over to GitHub because
Caption: they found that for their users the vast
Caption: majority of rumor screen reader users
Caption: GitHub was a very easy way for them to
Caption: submit bugs
Caption: if you want to do this well there are a
Caption: bunch of resources for it the web
Caption: content accessibility guides are sort of
Caption: the canonical resource but if you find
Caption: those too difficult or if you're doing
Caption: this for the first time and you want
Caption: something that's a bit easier to
Caption: understand the accessibility project has
Caption: produced a checklist where you can just
Caption: go down the checklist and it conveys it
Caption: all to you in a much simpler Manner and
Caption: you can pretty much just tick boxes to
Caption: work out do you actually follow the
Caption: guidelines
Caption: one thing that I don't talk very much
Caption: about in this talk is designing for
Caption: intellectual and cognitive disabilities
Caption: but the main resource that you're going
Caption: to want for that is the U.S federal
Caption: plain language guidelines these are
Caption: published by the US government and they
Caption: provide you instructions on how to use
Caption: plain clear English which is going to be
Caption: easier for people with intellectual and
Caption: cognitive disabilities to understand
Caption: and there's a blind lady called Christy
Caption: viers who produced a video which went
Caption: viral on Twitter showing how she uses
Caption: her iPhone and this I think is a really
Caption: important thing for people to see not
Caption: because
Caption: well because it shows you what's
Caption: possible when you think outside the box
Caption: and when you design these things taking
Caption: into account a wide variety of different
Caption: perspectives the iPhone has Braille
Caption: keyboards it has a great number of
Caption: haptic touch features which deliver data
Caption: that you would usually only get visually
Caption: in the resources for accessible design
Caption: there are a there's a web page which
Caption: links to a whole list of different
Caption: resources I'm going to call out a few of
Caption: them here that I think are important and
Caption: the first one is the ax core
Caption: accessibility testing Library
Caption: now this is very important for
Caption: accessibility because it is entirely
Caption: open source and it's what Google's
Caption: accessibility Checker and a lot of other
Caption: similar things are built on
Caption: the color Oracle desktop filter is a
Caption: very important one for color blindness
Caption: and the reason why I'm calling this tool
Caption: out specifically is there are a bunch of
Caption: browser extensions that you can get but
Caption: the color Oracle desktop filter is the
Caption: only one that will allow you to plug it
Caption: into desktop applications as well so if
Caption: you're developing a desktop application
Caption: rather than a web application that's a
Caption: very useful tool
Caption: if you want to test what you're doing
Caption: with a screen reader the patch yellow
Caption: group one of the very early
Caption: accessibility consultancies produced a
Caption: list of basic screen reader commands for
Caption: pretty much all of the common screen
Caption: readers and you can just get those up on
Caption: a computer and try them out yourself
Caption: Additionally the researchers at the
Caption: University of Maryland produce the
Caption: photosensitive epilepsy analysis tool a
Caption: few years ago and that one is really
Caption: important because photosensitive
Caption: epilepsy is a disability that we can't
Caption: ask people to test for if you're asking
Caption: people to test for that and they have a
Caption: seizure that's potentially going to be
Caption: threatening to their health or in the
Caption: worst case threatening to their life so
Caption: the researchers at the University of
Caption: Maryland produce this tool which
Caption: basically allows you to check the
Caption: contrast and animations on your website
Caption: to ensure that they're not going to be a
Caption: problem for people with photosensitive
Caption: epilepsy
Caption: now guidelines are great guidelines are
Caption: a really good starting point but
Caption: guidelines do not tell the whole story
Caption: this really comes down to that often
Caption: misused adage of the 80 20 principle and
Caption: I'll sum it up like this
Caption: the vast majority of accessibility
Caption: issues that you might run into can be
Caption: very easily solved by looking at and
Caption: understanding the guidelines
Caption: but there are some accessibility issues
Caption: that the guidelines don't cover and
Caption: there are situations where the
Caption: guidelines are misleading
Caption: in those sorts of scenarios what you
Caption: want to do is make sure that you have a
Caption: clear and understandable path for people
Caption: who have those issues to come to you
Caption: report them
Caption: and get them to the right people so that
Caption: they are going to be actioned
Caption: and with most accessibility talks this
Caption: is the point at which the person giving
Caption: the talk would explain to you how to
Caption: solve one particular problem in one
Caption: particular language for one particular
Caption: scenario
Caption: this is not one of that talks and the
Caption: reason for that is because I think it's
Caption: often very instructive to look at the
Caption: ways that people do this wrong
Caption: so that we can learn from them and
Caption: hopefully not repeat the mistakes
Caption: this is atlassian Confluence and my
Caption: assumption is that the vast majority of
Caption: the people in the audience here have
Caption: used atlassian Confluence before for
Caption: those of you who haven't it's basically
Caption: a shared documentation Wiki so you've
Caption: got a test space here you've got a bunch
Caption: of data you can click around it you can
Caption: go in and create pages and when you
Caption: click the button to create a page you
Caption: get something back that looks a bit like
Caption: this
Caption: and that looks fine right
Caption: but we're gonna go back and look at that
Caption: again because despite the fact that this
Caption: page was created in my test space which
Caption: you can see because my name is up there
Caption: I actually wasn't the person who created
Caption: it it was created by someone called
Caption: Matthew Gregory and at the time that I
Caption: first gave this talk Matt was my manager
Caption: so why was it that Matt was the person
Caption: who was creating this page and not me
Caption: well
Caption: that would be your answer because when I
Caption: went into Confluence back in the day and
Caption: I tried to create Pages what I would get
Caption: is that the button there would be cut
Caption: off the bottom of the screen which meant
Caption: that I could not navigate to it which
Caption: meant that I could not create pages
Caption: oops
Caption: so you can actually scroll the options
Caption: within the Confluence pop-up and
Caption: atlassian have done a bit of work in
Caption: fixing this since but
Caption: what this essentially meant at the time
Caption: was that if you were using a magnified
Caption: screen for particular configurations
Caption: because you couldn't scroll the whole
Caption: screen to see the whole pop-up you just
Caption: wouldn't be able to create Pages at all
Caption: or you would have to learn how to tab
Caption: navigate your way around blind without
Caption: screen reader cues to be able to do it
Caption: and that pretty much meant that that was
Caption: a piece of work that I just offloaded
Caption: onto my colleagues every time I needed
Caption: to create a page I called someone over
Caption: and I went hey can you come do this for
Caption: me please
Caption: so how do we improve it
Caption: well you want to make sure that your UI
Caption: elements are all scrollable and that
Caption: nothing is cut off by the bottom of the
Caption: screen so you want to set it up so that
Caption: it's not just you know scrolling the
Caption: options within the pop-up that the whole
Caption: page there is scrollable
Caption: you want to make sure that you test your
Caption: pop-up windows for accessibility so
Caption: looking at things like do they block out
Caption: other elements of the user interface if
Caption: someone is using a zoomed in screen or a
Caption: screen reader can they actually navigate
Caption: their way around this pop-up window
Caption: without losing focus without things
Caption: being cut off the bottom of the screen
Caption: and the best way to deal with it is you
Caption: zooming up yourself or you find a
Caption: visually impaired person you get them to
Caption: test it for you and that will very
Caption: quickly show you where a lot of those
Caption: issues are going to be
Caption: I need a human screen reader now I was
Caption: not the person who said this the person
Caption: who said I need a human screen reader
Caption: was my friend's grandmother she is
Caption: unfortunately now deceased she was a
Caption: lovely person and later on in life due
Caption: to a degenerative disease she became
Caption: blind now she was quite religious and
Caption: she used the pathos website which built
Caption: itself as hosting the conversation on
Caption: faith to keep in touch with her
Caption: religious community when she was no
Caption: longer able to easily go to church
Caption: and when she started using papayos many
Caption: many years ago it looked like this
Caption: and Visually that site is not too bad it
Caption: was also not all that bad to navigate
Caption: with a screen reader it wasn't perfect
Caption: but you could see where things were you
Caption: could relatively easily navigate your
Caption: way around most of it and it was fairly
Caption: apparent what was going on where they
Caption: also designed it in such a way that you
Caption: didn't have Auto playing videos and
Caption: cluttered pop-ups which would come up
Caption: and block your view of part of the page
Caption: until in late 2017 early 2018 pathos
Caption: went through a redesign and at the end
Caption: of the redesign their website looked
Caption: like this
Caption: and I can't show you the accessibility
Caption: issues with their website
Caption: because some of the problems that they
Caption: had were so bad that at the time I was
Caption: originally putting this talk together a
Caption: lot of the major browsers released a
Caption: feature that blocked a lot of these
Caption: obnoxious pop-ups on site that the
Caption: beginning of that text there
Caption: advertisement
Caption: I wasn't using an ad blocker when I did
Caption: this that was just blocked but back in
Caption: the day when my friend's grandmother was
Caption: trying to use this website what would
Caption: happen was she would tab around and
Caption: suddenly she would find herself in an ad
Caption: pop-up or there would be Auto playing
Caption: videos that were talking over her screen
Caption: reader which meant that she couldn't
Caption: hear the cues that she needed to
Caption: navigate around the website and that
Caption: made her feel something like this
Caption: she was not happy she was not very
Caption: pleased and she no longer used the
Caption: pathos website
Caption: if you want an example of this closer to
Caption: home Coles the big supermarket chain got
Caption: sued by a screen reader user because of
Caption: their website for online ordering was
Caption: not accessible with a screen reader
Caption: and Coles ended up settling that lawsuit
Caption: and one of the stipulations of the
Caption: settlement was that Coles actually had
Caption: to make sure that their online website
Caption: was accessible to screen reader users so
Caption: if you want to have a look at someone
Caption: who does this really well causes it and
Caption: that's because now they know they have
Caption: to do it
Caption: oops
Caption: so the sound on auto playing videos
Caption: talks over screen readers and when you
Caption: think about the fact that screen readers
Caption: are providing auditor cues to help you
Caption: with the visual cues that you miss if
Caption: your vision impaired that can be quite a
Caption: big problem but the bigger problem is
Caption: that if you can't see the video on the
Caption: page you're relying on being able to
Caption: hear the screen readers triggers that
Caption: will tell you how to close it if the
Caption: video is talking over the screen reader
Caption: that's not something that you're going
Caption: to be able to do
Caption: and what's even worse is that some of
Caption: these pop-up advertisements and auto
Caption: playing videos will actually take screen
Caption: readers into an entirely new container
Caption: which acts as a new page and then you
Caption: just get a bunch of triggers that go
Caption: image image image item text and so on
Caption: and so forth looping around
Caption: and if you are a screen reader user
Caption: expecting to see a whole page and you
Caption: don't know what's happened that can be
Caption: really confusing
Caption: to make matters worse not all pop-ups
Caption: and auto playing videos have a dismiss
Caption: button that won't even work if you don't
Caption: have a mouse there are some scenarios in
Caption: which you set up your whole page and you
Caption: go through and you try and make sure
Caption: that you can actually close things and
Caption: you find that that close Trigger or that
Caption: dismiss trigger just isn't visible if
Caption: you're navigating via keyboard it's not
Caption: correctly placed and that can be a
Caption: really big problem
Caption: so how do we improve it well it's pretty
Caption: good design just let people decide
Caption: whether they want to play videos Auto
Caption: playing videos are really annoying and
Caption: it is even more important to let users
Caption: decide because of the accessibility
Caption: implications of this
Caption: you also want to make it easy for
Caption: keyboard Navigators and screen reader
Caption: users to ignore or close those pop-up
Caption: elements so make sure that the dismiss
Caption: trigger is easily visible to a screen
Caption: reader make sure that it's very early on
Caption: make sure that it's placed in the sort
Caption: of location that they would think it
Caption: would be
Caption: now Safari has a reader mode a lot of
Caption: other browsers have reader mode
Caption: extensions there's even one you can get
Caption: for the CLI which I probably need to go
Caption: back and add to the sources at some
Caption: point
Caption: but what reader mode essentially does is
Caption: it strips out everything on the website
Caption: except for the text and the images and
Caption: that can be a really useful fullback for
Caption: blind or visually impaired people
Caption: because the screen reader is then going
Caption: to be able to readily navigate around it
Caption: so do check to make sure that your HTML
Caption: is properly formatted check to make sure
Caption: that reader mode works the way that you
Caption: would expect it to
Caption: and then put on a blindfold cover your
Caption: screen use a screen reader yourself it's
Caption: not going to be as good as getting
Caption: people who use it day to day but you
Caption: will very quickly pick up on what the
Caption: issues might be when you do a direct
Caption: comparison of what the screen reader
Caption: gives you to what you actually get when
Caption: you look at it visually
Caption: does anyone here remember geocities
Caption: cool yup we have an audience of people
Caption: that remember geocities
Caption: those of you who don't geoseties
Caption: websites tended to look something like
Caption: this this is admittedly one of the less
Caption: obnoxious options that I could have
Caption: picked but it's still very emblematic of
Caption: what web design in that sort of era was
Caption: like we've got the word up we've got the
Caption: dancing penguin we've got a bunch of
Caption: clashing colors we've got broken links
Caption: we've got a whole lot of text in
Caption: different colors in Thai
Caption: um all that we're really missing is you
Caption: know the line of rainbow Kirby's jumping
Caption: across the top and then it would be very
Caption: much a geocities website
Caption: geocities is dead Yahoo bought it and
Caption: they killed it off in March of 2019.
Caption: fortunately or unfortunately depending
Caption: on how you look at it a lot of the
Caption: people who came into web design in the
Caption: era where geocities were state of the
Caption: art
Caption: now actually have quite a lot of
Caption: creative control over their own websites
Caption: and many of them have Incorporated some
Caption: of these elements of the geocities era
Caption: into their corporate websites which is
Caption: essentially the equivalent of taking
Caption: your very productive businesses fancy
Caption: corporate website we are very amazing
Caption: and we will show you why
Caption: and putting a Nyan cat across the top of
Caption: it which is not something I'm going to
Caption: recommend unless whatever your business
Caption: is is very very niche
Caption: I have a friend who has photosensitive
Caption: epilepsy and she works in the IT
Caption: industry several years ago she had an
Caption: encounter with one of these enterprising
Caption: designers from the geocities era
Caption: she heard about this particular tech
Caption: company and she wanted to see what they
Caption: were all about and so she went to their
Caption: website
Caption: and what she encountered there was a
Caption: giant strobing Pink element that took up
Caption: the top two-thirds of her screen
Caption: which pretty much immediately caused her
Caption: to have a seizure and the end result of
Caption: that was that the enterprising designer
Caption: had a phone call which I really
Caption: suspected he probably didn't want to be
Caption: on the other end of
Caption: oops
Caption: so flashing flickering and strobing
Caption: effects are one of the major causes of
Caption: seizures and if you're a video game
Caption: player and you get games in physical
Caption: boxes if you flip over to the back of
Caption: the game quite often they have that
Caption: little bit of text there that says hey
Caption: there's a flashing flickering and
Caption: strobing warning here if you're
Caption: photosensitive you want to be careful
Caption: about playing this that's what that is
Caption: for
Caption: and it's much more severe generally if
Caption: you're looking at saturated Reds pinks
Caption: oranges and really high contrast effect
Caption: so if you're strobing something from
Caption: pink to white or red to White that's
Caption: going to be much more of a problem than
Caption: a tiny little animation in the corner
Caption: that's going dark blue to dark green
Caption: particularly because photosensitive
Caption: epilepsy is a spectrum from mild to
Caption: severe
Caption: at the milder end it's quite easy to
Caption: work out but my friend being one of the
Caption: more severe cases runs into this more
Caption: often than she should and so you've got
Caption: to be aware then of what the parameters
Caption: are that you're dealing with
Caption: so how do we improve it well to begin
Caption: with if you can you want to avoid using
Caption: those flashing flickering and strobing
Caption: effects
Caption: if you do need to use them the two
Caption: changes that you want to make are you
Caption: want to make sure that they are low
Caption: contrast and you want to make sure that
Caption: they're as small as possible that
Caption: flashing from dark blue to dark green in
Caption: the corner is not going to be nearly as
Caption: much of a problem as the giant strobing
Caption: Pink element that takes up the top two
Caption: thirds of your page
Caption: and if you can avoid it don't use
Caption: particularly saturated Reds and pinks
Caption: and also sometimes oranges for those
Caption: sorts of flashing effects
Caption: if you really want to do this well and
Caption: you have a website where you absolutely
Caption: have to have animation on it give users
Caption: the option to disable and enable it at
Caption: will that's the sort of thing that's
Caption: really useful for scenarios like Ling's
Caption: cars because it means that if you have
Caption: people who have those sorts of
Caption: photosensitivity issues they can still
Caption: actually access your website even if
Caption: it's not quite in the way that you might
Caption: have intended
Caption: now there is actually a certain amount
Caption: of precedent for disabled people being
Caption: involved in integrated Sports and that
Caption: can be everything from kids playing in
Caption: the schoolyard to Olympic Champions like
Caption: rato ildico the Hungarian fencer and
Caption: imdong Hyun the Korean Archer
Caption: but for this specific case study I want
Caption: to look at a more modern version of
Caption: sports we're going to look at Esports
Caption: specifically League of Legends
Caption: this is for those of you who are not
Caption: into video games pretty much a
Caption: computerized Tower Defense you have
Caption: teams of five people and they're trying
Caption: to defend a tower
Caption: each of the people on those five teams
Caption: can pick characters or Champions that
Caption: have different abilities and League of
Caption: Legends has a really thriving
Caption: professional scene you can actually make
Caption: a decent living playing League of
Caption: Legends professionally if you're very
Caption: good at it
Caption: several years ago the creators of League
Caption: of Legends introduced a new Champion
Caption: called Tom kench and this is the titular
Caption: catfish you can see there redfish on the
Caption: left and green fish on the right
Caption: time can turn a mechanic that no other
Caption: character in the game had had before and
Caption: that mechanic is called gray health and
Caption: this is where we find out how many
Caption: colorblind people are in the audience
Caption: today because for those of you who are
Caption: not colorblind if you have a look at
Caption: that on the red side you can see that
Caption: there's a chunk of the health bar that's
Caption: red then there's a big chunk of the
Caption: health bar that's great and that's
Caption: essentially acting as a shield which
Caption: means that at this point Tom kench is
Caption: unkillable and then on the right hand
Caption: side you've got that little bit which is
Caption: kind of shaded out red and that's the
Caption: health that he's lost
Caption: but if I put a color blindness filter
Caption: over that particularly on the left side
Caption: the red side which is the enemy side
Caption: that's suddenly not so clear
Caption: and given that somewhere between eight
Caption: and ten percent of the population mostly
Caption: men are colorblind it was inevitable
Caption: that when with teams of five you are
Caption: eventually going to have a tweet like
Caption: this from a professional player if you
Caption: didn't know I'm colorblind along with
Caption: two other members of my team all three
Caption: of us can't see what health he's at in
Caption: colorblind mode he being Tom kenchier
Caption: again these are professional players
Caption: this is something that they need to be
Caption: able to do to do their job
Caption: so most colorblind people can't tell the
Caption: difference between red and green but as
Caption: you can see there from the colorblind
Caption: filter the other crucial bit of
Caption: information here is the contrast between
Caption: colors if you can't distinguish the
Caption: difference between particular colors
Caption: you're going to use that contrast to see
Caption: is this what I think it is or is it not
Caption: because what you basically get with
Caption: colors that colorblind people can't see
Caption: is they'll generally look some variation
Caption: of gray black brown or black or they'll
Caption: be ambiguous
Caption: and the way that we improve this to
Caption: start with is by using a contrast
Caption: Checker to make sure that elements are
Caption: going to be viewable
Caption: to people with all different types of
Caption: color blindness and I'm not just talking
Caption: about red and green color blindness here
Caption: which are the most common types you also
Caption: need to design for blue color blindness
Caption: and people with no color vision at all
Caption: slack does this really well slack for
Caption: many years has had accessibility themes
Caption: for protonopia and deuteronopia so red
Caption: green color blindness but also Patrician
Caption: appeal which is blue GitHub is another
Caption: one that more recently has done that
Caption: very well
Caption: and even if you have a colorblind mode
Caption: particularly if you're just designing
Caption: for red and green color blindness try
Caption: putting a filter over get people to test
Caption: it and make sure that it actually does
Caption: what you think it would do right games
Caption: the creators of League of Legends to
Caption: their credit did actually fix this quite
Caption: quickly when it came to their attention
Caption: but it's that sort of user acceptance
Caption: testing that can often pick up those
Caption: issues before they get to production
Caption: and if you're building a colorblind mode
Caption: for something you want to try and make
Caption: sure that you're using meaningful icons
Caption: or meaningful information to indicate
Caption: different elements in state not just
Caption: color if what you're getting is you know
Caption: we're using a square a circle on a
Caption: rectangle to try to tell difference
Caption: between these things that's not much
Caption: better whereas if you've got a great big
Caption: tick
Caption: it's going to be apparent what it means
Caption: whether it's green or not
Caption: it's 2020 round three and I can't
Caption: believe I'm saying this but if we cast
Caption: our mind back a few years to 2020 round
Caption: one
Caption: before the whole covert pandemic thing
Caption: happened you might remember I certainly
Caption: do in Melbourne we had pretty extensive
Caption: bushfires which blanketed quite a lot of
Caption: the country in Smoke and through
Caption: bushfires and through the covid-19
Caption: pandemic a lot of people became aware of
Caption: different aspects of accessibility that
Caption: they hadn't been aware of before and one
Caption: of these was sign language interpreters
Caption: because every time we had the prime
Caption: minister or a premier or a chief Health
Caption: officer or someone from the Emergency
Caption: Services coming onto our televisions
Caption: giving broadcasts there was always an
Caption: Australian sign language interpreter
Caption: next to them and that was to ensure that
Caption: for people where sign language is their
Caption: first language they were able to get
Caption: that information conveyed to them in a
Caption: timely manner in case they needed to
Caption: evacuate or to make sure that they knew
Caption: what health orders were changing
Caption: but sign language interpretation is not
Caption: the only way to make things accessible
Caption: to people who are deaf or hard of
Caption: hearing
Caption: you also want to look at things like
Caption: captions and a lot of people will do
Caption: that using automated captioning
Caption: Solutions
Caption: which can be great until they're not as
Caption: illustrated by this tweet from Kell
Caption: Montgomery a disability activist beta
Caption: based out of the US
Caption: if you value US equally and want us to
Caption: participate fully we need full access to
Caption: the Paul say briefing with enough lead
Caption: time to absorb it
Caption: that chance is gone for this year which
Caption: means that you have just sabotaged your
Caption: own legislative agenda by leaving
Caption: Advocates unprepared
Caption: Now cal here was referring to one of the
Caption: biggest disability organizations in the
Caption: U.S who had run an event the Paul say
Caption: briefing and if you're wondering what
Caption: Paul say means that's how the automated
Caption: captioning solution that they said was
Caption: adequate for people to access that
Caption: briefing rendered the term policy
Caption: the rest of the the rest of the
Caption: transcript of the briefing was similarly
Caption: garbled
Caption: now that's actually not that hard to
Caption: solve it just requires a bit of human
Caption: review afterwards and one group of
Caption: people that do this really well are the
Caption: podcasts This American Life which is
Caption: backed by national public radio in the
Caption: US
Caption: they do have a note on their website
Caption: that says This American Life is produced
Caption: for the ear and designed to be heard
Caption: but they produce transcripts which are
Caption: run through an automated transcription
Caption: engine and then corrected manually by
Caption: human captioners and what that means is
Caption: that if you are deaf if you are hard of
Caption: hearing or if you have auditory
Caption: processing issues or for any other
Caption: reason are text Reliant you can go
Caption: through and read through that transcript
Caption: and it will provide you with all of the
Caption: information
Caption: one group of people that don't do this
Caption: quite so well are Guardian Australia and
Caption: this is relevant because they produced
Caption: one of the better sources of information
Caption: in audio form about what was actually
Caption: going on in terms of health roundups and
Caption: things during the covid-19 pandemic
Caption: but their approach to transcribing
Caption: things can be described with this
Caption: headline here Guardian podcasts why no
Caption: transcripts
Caption: that is to say that their approach is to
Caption: not transcribe anything at all
Caption: which means that if you are deaf or hard
Caption: of hearing or otherwise text Reliant you
Caption: cannot actually access any of the
Caption: material that Guardian Australia
Caption: produces in audio form
Caption: oops
Caption: and this is also important because text
Caption: Reliant people aren't necessarily deaf
Caption: or hard of hearing autistic people
Caption: people with ADHD people with sensory
Caption: processing disorders people who are on a
Caption: busy train and want to be able to read
Caption: information rather than listening to it
Caption: people with disorders like tinnitus
Caption: which affect the hearing in situational
Caption: manners
Caption: are all going to find themselves text
Caption: Reliant at some point or another even if
Caption: it's not all the time
Caption: so how do we improve it
Caption: you want to provide transcripts for any
Caption: spoken audio on your website and you
Caption: want to make sure that you caption any
Caption: videos but do bear in mind that
Caption: automated transcription software is not
Caption: a complete solution if you get a human
Caption: to correct the transcription before it's
Caption: published you're going to produce
Caption: something that people can actually
Caption: access
Caption: and the captions which were done by
Caption: Netflix for stranger things sort of made
Caption: their way around the internet multiple
Caption: times because they did a lot of other
Caption: things really well in terms of
Caption: describing changes in vocal tone and
Caption: background noise if you're producing
Caption: particularly video content or complex
Caption: video content that's really important
Caption: acting in artificial pancreas now that
Caption: can be read in two different ways we can
Caption: talk about hacking together an
Caption: artificial pancreas or we can talk about
Caption: hacking into an artificial pancreas
Caption: but this case study actually covers both
Caption: this is a Medtronic mini-med insulin
Caption: pump it is used by people who are
Caption: insulin dependent with diabetes
Caption: basically the pump sits just under your
Caption: skin you plug it in and it delivers
Caption: insulin at regular intervals without you
Caption: having to inject yourself that's really
Caption: good for a lot of people
Caption: there's also been another recent
Caption: invention of the constant blood glucose
Caption: monitor
Caption: and that again similarly sits just below
Caption: your skin provides information on what
Caption: your blood glucose is all the time and
Caption: these Medtronic minimet insulin pumps
Caption: had a really interesting security flaw
Caption: which resulted in a lot of people with
Caption: diabetes hunting them down because what
Caption: you could do is there was an unsecured
Caption: radio frequency which was used by the
Caption: remote but you could also hook that up
Caption: with a bridge between it and a little
Caption: bit of open source source code
Caption: to a constant blood glucose monitor and
Caption: have the insulin pump react and deliver
Caption: insulin at various intervals based on
Caption: that
Caption: but the problem is
Caption: that security flaws always come with
Caption: other issues and the fact that you could
Caption: hook in Via this piece of source code
Caption: also meant that your Medtronic MiniMed
Caption: insulin pump was potentially vulnerable
Caption: to hacker attacks
Caption: which is not great because that allows
Caption: you to actually modify the amount of
Caption: insulin that you give to someone
Caption: so the FDA the drug regulator in the US
Caption: were made aware of this and they went
Caption: away and issued an alert on it
Caption: but there were a few enterprising hacker
Caption: types in the healthcare industry who
Caption: didn't think that they were taking this
Caption: very seriously so they got out their
Caption: phones and they did a little bit of
Caption: coding and they produced an Android app
Caption: which you could use to hook into that
Caption: really common frequency on any Medtronic
Caption: mini-med insulin pump in the immediate
Caption: vicinity and either entirely withhold
Caption: insulin from its user or deliver a
Caption: lethal dose of insulin immediately
Caption: which finally resulted in Medtronic
Caption: recalling their vulnerable Mini Med
Caption: insulin pumps
Caption: oh dear
Caption: and this is where we get into the fact
Caption: that accessibility is not just about web
Caption: accessibility in some scenarios security
Caption: issues and many other types of issues
Caption: can actually be accessibility problems
Caption: medical devices you're dealing with
Caption: people's lives it's really important and
Caption: what's more problematic is that if
Caption: you're regulated by an external
Caption: organization like the FDA you may not
Caption: hear about these issues quickly in some
Caption: scenarios you may not actually hear
Caption: about them at all
Caption: so how do we improve this you want to
Caption: start by considering the possible attack
Caption: factors a lot of this is just good basic
Caption: security get a good pen testing company
Caption: in particularly Hardware pen testers for
Caption: stuff like medical devices before your
Caption: device goes to Market
Caption: and make sure that if people notify you
Caption: about security vulnerabilities you
Caption: respond promptly
Caption: because the really sad thing about this
Caption: use case is that unintended users can
Caption: actually be a business opportunity and
Caption: Medtronic weren't the ones that ended up
Caption: capitalizing on it there were a couple
Caption: of different companies who saw these
Caption: issues and produced secure insulin pumps
Caption: which were set up properly which you
Caption: could use to hook into derivatives of
Caption: that original source code on a secure
Caption: channel to produce your closed loop
Caption: insulin delivery system
Caption: and this is where we get to my favorite
Caption: case study of the bunch because this is
Caption: another one that concerns me
Caption: I have been giving this talk since 2019.
Caption: and when I realized that I was going to
Caption: be talking to people a lot about
Caption: accessibility when I became an
Caption: accidental accessibility advocate
Caption: I went okay I've got to find some way of
Caption: making sure that I know about what is
Caption: going on in the accessibility world and
Caption: one way that I did that was through my
Caption: LinkedIn feed
Caption: so I was looking a lot of information
Caption: about accessibility I was following the
Caption: accessibility hashtag and one day I was
Caption: going through my LinkedIn feed and a
Caption: post popped up saying there's an
Caption: accessibility consultant that's giving a
Caption: talk about accessibility on this date at
Caption: this time at this venue
Caption: and I went great cool I know some things
Caption: about accessibility I know quite a lot
Caption: about the things that are directly
Caption: applicable to me as well as more about
Caption: the things that are applicable to my
Caption: friends people that I know but there's
Caption: always something that you can learn from
Caption: scenarios like this
Caption: so I go along I get off work at 4 30 I
Caption: take the train to venue
Caption: to see this
Caption: that's a set of steps
Caption: that wasn't the only set of stairs to
Caption: get into the building there were in fact
Caption: three similar sets of stairs that one
Caption: and two more after the glass door to get
Caption: to the lift which would then take you up
Caption: to where the event was being held
Caption: and I described this to a couple of
Caption: friends of mine as being like a Roomba
Caption: just sitting at the bottom of a set of
Caption: stairs repeatedly shouting error 406
Caption: which for those of you who are not well
Caption: versed in HTML error codes means not
Caption: acceptable
Caption: so I get up there I listen to the whole
Caption: talk and I had basically crawled up I I
Caption: basically called up the last flight of
Caption: stairs to get there
Caption: and I said to the accessibility
Caption: consultant does it strike you as ironic
Caption: that you're giving a talk about web
Caption: accessibility in a venue that's
Caption: inaccessible and he looks at me and he
Caption: goes
Caption: you know I hadn't really thought about
Caption: that
Caption: and I don't think that I need to explain
Caption: the irony here but we're going to do the
Caption: postmortem anyway
Caption: so if you're running events and full
Caption: credit to DDD perk here because they've
Caption: done a brilliant job of this you want to
Caption: make sure that your venues are
Caption: wheelchair accessible you want to make
Caption: sure that they have disabled bathrooms I
Caption: so many times I have gone to events to
Caption: find that the disabled bathrooms are on
Caption: a different floor or they're locked or
Caption: no one knows where they are or you've
Caption: got to go and talk to security to
Caption: actually get the key
Caption: but there are more advanced types of
Caption: things that you can do which help people
Caption: with a variety of different disabilities
Caption: so you want to look at things like
Caption: providing quiet spaces for people which
Caption: again is something that DDD Perth has
Caption: done and making sure that there is a lot
Caption: of different adaptive technology around
Caption: so sign language interpreters if you've
Caption: got hearing loops one of my friends has
Caption: been hard of hearing basically her whole
Caption: life when got fitted with a hearing aid
Caption: in her 40s and she called me up and she
Caption: said Dawn I am so happy because For the
Caption: First Time I can hear the announcements
Caption: at the train station when I turn on my
Caption: hearing aid and I plug it into the
Caption: hearing Loop
Caption: and things like you know audio
Caption: descriptions of slides you'll see as I
Caption: go through this talk I've tried to
Caption: describe everything that's on the slides
Caption: as I go but what's really important here
Caption: is making sure that you include people
Caption: with disabilities in discussions about
Caption: accessibility and if you don't know
Caption: whether people with disabilities are the
Caption: question that you need to ask yourself
Caption: and again this is not just applicable to
Caption: disability is who's not in the room and
Caption: why aren't they here because sometimes
Caption: the reason why they aren't here is going
Caption: to be as simple as three flights of
Caption: stairs into the venue
Caption: so to recap accessibility benefits
Caption: everyone not just disabled people
Caption: and you can do this really well by
Caption: building accessibility into your design
Caption: principles from the start but it's not
Caption: just about the web accessibility piece
Caption: other issues like security risks can
Caption: also be accessibility issues you need to
Caption: make an individualized assessment based
Caption: on what it is that you're trying to do
Caption: excuse me my slides are stuffing up
Caption: again
Caption: thorough testing is really important and
Caption: the best case scenario is that you can
Caption: get adaptive technology users to test
Caption: your software themselves but if you
Caption: can't think about the things that
Caption: disabled people might need to do
Caption: differently and most importantly
Caption: regardless of whether they have
Caption: accessibility needs or not listen to
Caption: your users
Caption: I do want to give a couple of thanks to
Caption: Melissa who did my former colleague who
Caption: did the fancy website mock-ups for me
Caption: Matt for the atlassian Confluence
Caption: screenshots and my friend Annie who
Caption: produced the accessibility Roomba
Caption: drawing
Caption: we're not going to have time for
Caption: questions I'll be around I have colored
Caption: hair I'm not hard to find come find me
Caption: my email is up there there's also a link
Caption: there to GitHub repo which has all of
Caption: the talks that I've previously done and
Caption: I've done a million different talks on
Caption: accessibility but it was amazing to be
Caption: here to do this in person for a group of
Caption: people for the first time and thank you
Caption: all so much for coming on this journey
Caption: with me
Caption: foreign